in the House of Commons conservative
leader Pierre poliev delivered a lengthy
speech in an attempt to delay the
adoption of the federal budget
I am Rising today to speak
[Applause]
and to speak and to speak
for the people who have no voice
the people who are have been silenced
for too long
the leaders filibuster lasted more than
three and a half hours before the house
adjourned for the evening earlier
Wednesday pauliev said he would speak
non-stop to block the budget's passage
until the Prime Minister commits to a
balanced budget on Monday Finance
Minister Christian Freeland called the
conservative party tactics adolescent
partisan games and parliamentary
childishness
yesterday spoke for four hours to stop
the inflationary tax hiking Trudeau
budget
now I did this not just because I
disagree with the irresponsible
overspending that has caused the
inflation I for long believed that but
because I believe we're headed to a very
serious crisis
since the Prime Minister introduced his
budget there have been three major
developments one
the international monetary fund has
identified Canada as the country most at
risk
of a mortgage meltdown
because we have the biggest household
debt of any country in the G7 two
trillion dollars of household debt in
fact our households have as much debt as
the entire GDP combined
the second inflation is now again on the
rise something the Prime Minister
promised was not going to happen he
claimed inflation was just going to fall
now it's rising a surprise when you pour
tens of billions of dollars more of
spending into the economy you get more
inflation and third the unexpected
increase in interest rates that is going
to be another uppercut to overly
indebted Canadians who already can't
afford their bills I want you to think
about this for a second if this is if
you have a family that's paying three
thousand dollars a month on mortgages
and they experience with the Bank of
Canada projects will be a 40 percent
increase in their monthly mortgage
payment
that's thirteen hundred dollars a month
which is almost fifteen thousand dollars
a year when half of our households don't
even have two hundred dollars left in
their bank account
what is going to happen over the next
three years as all of these Mega
mortgages Renew at these higher rates
we're going to have defaults we're going
to have mass fire sales of homes as
people uh can't make their payment and
all they can do is put their house in
the market but there won't be anyone to
buy them because no one else is going to
afford to pay the rates either
this could be a major Financial meltdown
this is not me saying it it's the IMF
it's the Bank of Canada the Prime
Minister has to recognize these facts
have changed since he introduced his
budget and so I'm calling on him to do
The Honorable thing
to put aside his pride and his personal
ego
and cancel this budget